this reporter that met Messi and then
started crying I don't understand soccer
though I don't get it Doug I don't get
it that's how soft the sport is bro yeah
look at messy though the reporter
flopped
[Laughter]
he said he wanted a moment so bad bro he
wants a moment so bad and then she's not
gonna die I ain't giving this to you bro
I mean kind of crazy though is there any
way you could interview that would make
you cry
truly no one yeah I don't think so that
you would cry I love crying I love it
but no come on yeah Michael Irvin would
have been that person for you and you
think I don't know like a little [ __ ]
yeah giddy yeah I don't I don't know why
you would cry
maybe it's like
he's like me and somebody he was like a
kid or something I don't know do you
think it's the Personal Achievement
like he's been following the sport for
so long and he's been idolizing the best
player in the sport and he's like my
career will be fulfilled not anymore are
you crying ass idiot
ruin that whole moment dummy dumbass but
then you've never had moments like where
you're like wow like I accomplished that
and then you got emotional thousand
percent in private like a man yeah yeah
yeah in front of the person it's also
yes can you imagine if I sat in Rogan
and just started [ __ ] tearing up
right there it's never it's never in the
moment right like that's clip of the win
when broken started laughing at me yeah
it's such an order to be here I've
thought about this moment my whole life
he's just like what did I try to help
because of you
can I give you a hug No don't touch me
yeah yeah I don't know I'm like I I
think about all the achievements you've
had in your life do you think would you
cry in the achievement or would you I
was afterwards be in the shower and be
like holy [ __ ] that really happened
shower or flight flight is the best one
that's that's not fair that's ped's yeah
it is true yes but like yeah that nice
cry on a flight hoodie up leaning into
the window fake looking out have we
talked about how your tongue gets numb
on flights mine doesn't get enough have
you heard this no but like your taste
buds get less sensitive on a flight it
tastes like this but not your tongue
getting no no not no but like yeah your
taste buds like you can't taste food the
same way is that true have we talked
about
it
yeah and you said like they have to over
salt food apparently yeah yeah oh is
that why I'm thirsty as [ __ ] on a
goddamn plane well there's also just no
moisture you're getting dehydrated uh
yeah you get very dehydrated and flying
I'm telling you that [ __ ] is not natural
for humans ears are popping out of your
[ __ ] head you're dehydrated you're
crying for no reason
not natural
is ecstasy less natural than mushrooms
oh my God it does not waste everybody's
time